Speaker 1: Why don't we speak next to Jill
from Burbank?
Jill, welcome.
Jill, welcome to the program.
Speaker 2: Hey, can you hear me, baby?
Yes.
Okay.
Perfect.
I have basically one question.
How can we take seriously a party, which is
the Republican Party?
Yeah, that is pro coup pro, you know, traitors
pro.
Anti-Democrat.
ANTI-democracy.
Democracy.
How can regular people take them seriously
and consider them as a party like a major
party?
Speaker 1: Well, because we have a very sick
country.
I mean, you're pointing out something, Jill,
which is it's astute in its simplicity in
much of the world.
Your average person looks at the Democratic
Party, looks and then looks at the Republican
Party and says, wait a second.
So the Democrats are I mean, like, I'll give
you my opinion, the Democrats are not nearly
left enough.
But here's a list of 15 things they want to
do that seem reasonable, and they generally
support democracy and whatever.
And then you look at the Republican Party
and it's Trump's winning primaries.
They're doing everything from openly supporting,
stealing an election that they didn't win
all the way to, you know, more more minor
but insane stuff, like just making fun of
disabled reporters, all of it.
And in many countries, people would say there's
really only one option there.
You've got to vote for the Democratic Party.
That Republican stuff is crazy.
But we have a very sick country here and we
have a lot of people who don't see it that
way.
And they seem to love the Republican Party.
They seem to see it as a as a legitimate participant
in the political system.
And so, as I've said many times before, crazy
candidates and wild parties exist in many
parts of the world, but without millions of
people to vote for them, they don't really
go anywhere.
And the U.S. is so lucky that we have not
only the candidates but the people to vote
for them as well.
Speaker 2: But but I understand the crazy
people.
You know, we're actually not going to consider
these crazy people because, you know, they
always exist.
Yeah, this is about people.
My question is specifically, you know about
them.
How can the regular people of the United States
I know they're just 30% of the United States.
That is crazy.
But the rest are not regular.
You know, Joe Schmo going to work every day,
not following any politics.
Yeah, but when it comes to, you know, every
four years, okay, you know, they get a they
get a mail in ballot and they fill it out.
They do a little research and find out, hey,
I mean, they also saw what happened on January
6th.
Yeah.
How can you say that?
And be like, okay, no, you know what?
I'm going to go, you know, Republican Party.
That just does not make any sense to me at
all.
Speaker 1: I'm I'm with you.
And I think that so first of all, remember,
close to half the country doesn't vote.
So, first of all, half the country isn't even
voting.
So we can kind of eliminate them.
Of the half to 55% that does vote, half of
them vote for Democrats instead of Republicans.
Okay.
So now we're down to like 25% of the country.
Of the 25% of the country that votes for Republicans,
you've got basically three groups, the people
that are just ignorant to the facts.
And so we include we can include in this both
people who don't know anything and also supposedly
like the crazy people, the people that just
have no idea what's going on.
That's one group.
Then you have the bad people, okay?
These are people who they they see what's
going on and they want it.
They want to discriminate.
They want to separate children from family,
you know, all these different things.
And then you've got the third group, which
is people who they understand what's going
on and they have some selfish reason for voting
for Trump anyway.
Like they saw that he was crazy, but they
thought he would lower their taxes.
So.
So these are like the three groups.
So it's if you imagine that those groups exist
sort of evenly.
Each group of those is like 8% of the country.
That's a lot of people because the U.S. has
such a large population, but it's actually
not a huge percentage of the country.
Jill.
All right.
I guess Jill's gone.
Let's go next to Laura from Somerville.
Laura, welcome to the show.
Laura.
Speaker 2: Hello?
Hello.
Hi.
How are you?
Speaker 1: I'm doing well.
Speaker 2: Pretty well.
So I have a question about the midterms, please.
How much of an impact do you think that AIPAC
is going to have when it comes to.
The midterms, and maybe you've already covered
this elsewhere.
Speaker 1: I don't know.
I mean, I've not covered it.
Is are they are they having a particular impact?
I've heard nothing about AIPAC for years.
Laura.
Speaker 2: Sorry.
Are you able to find the funding?
Yeah.
Can you hear me?
Okay.
So in terms of funding towards campaigns that
are more pro-Palestinian.
Mm hmm.
Speaker 1: Are there particular campaigns
that you're I don't know if I'm losing half
of what you're saying, Laura, or if this is
the whole question.
Is there a particular race you're talking
about?
I mean, there's so many different PACs and
interest groups and they're all funding candidates
and opposing.
I just don't know if there was like a specific
race or something in particular that you had
on your mind.
Speaker 2: I think overall this across the
country, I've been hearing that just from
other sources.
I didn't know if you if you had an opinion
on that.
Speaker 1: No, no.
I just haven't heard that this particular
year that there's anything in particular happening.
Who are you hearing that from?
Laura.
All right.
Thank you, Laura.
I don't know what was going on there, but
very, very strange technical elements there.
Surprising